[Music]
following a devastating nuclear war
Lilith yopo awakens after 250 years of
stasis to find herself surrounded by a
group of aliens call the Oankali these
highly evolved beings want to trade DNA
by breeding with humans so that each
species genes can diversify and fortify
the other the only alternative they
offer is sterilization of the entire
human race should humanity take the leap
into the biological unknown or hold on
to its identity and perish questions
like this haunting auntie via butler's
Dawn the first in her trilogy
Lilith's brood a visionary storyteller
who upended science fiction Butler built
stunning worlds throughout her work and
explored dilemmas that keep us awake at
night born in 1947 Butler grew up shy
and introverted in Pasadena California
she dreamt up stories from an early age
and was soon scribbling these scenarios
on paper at 12 she begged her mother for
a typewriter after enduring a campy
science-fiction film called devil girl
from Mars unimpressed with what she saw
Butler knew she could tell a better
story much science fiction features
white male heroes who blast aliens or
become saviors of brown people
Butler wanted to write diverse
characters for diverse audiences
she brought nuance and depth to the
representation of their experiences for
Butler imagination was not only for
planting the seeds of science fiction
but also a strategy for surviving an
unjust world on one's own terms
her work often takes troubling features
of the world such as discrimination on
the basis of race gender class or
ability and invites the reader to
contemplate them in new context one of
her most beloved novels the parable of
the sower follows this pattern it tells
the story of Lauren oh yeah ol Amina as
she makes her way through a near-future
California ruined by corporate greed
inequality and environmental destruction
as she struggles with hyper empathy or
condition in the novel that causes her
to feel others pain and less often their
pleasure
Lauren embarks on a quest with a group
of refugees to find a place to thrive
there they seek to live in accordance
with Lawrence found religion earth seed
which is based on the principle that
humans must adapt to an ever-changing
world Laurens quest had roots in a
real-life event California prop 187
which attempted to deny undocumented
immigrants fundamental human rights
before it was deemed unconstitutional
Butler frequently incorporated
contemporary news into her writing in
her 1998 sequel to the parable of the
sower parable of the talents she wrote
of a presidential candidate who controls
Americans with virtual reality and shop
collars his slogan make America great
again while people have noted her
prescients Butler was also interested in
reexamining history for instance Kendra
tells a story of a woman who has
repeatedly pulled back in time to the
Maryland plantation of her ancestors
early on she learns that her mission is
to save the life of the white man who
will rape her great-grandmother if she
doesn't save him she herself will cease
to exist
this grim dilemma forces Dana to
confront the ongoing trauma of slavery
and sexual violence against black women
with her stories of women founding new
societies time travelers overcoming
historical strife and interspecies
bonding Butler had a profound influence
on the growing popularity of
afrofuturism that's a cultural movement
where black writers and artists who are
inspired by the past present and future
produce works that incorporate magic
history technology and much more as
Lauren comes to learn in parable of the
sower all that you touch you change all
that you change changes you the only
lasting truth is change
check out this playlist to keep learning
about other visionary authors
[Music]